all right the vikings are not nearly as
high on the list of our state of the
franchise as the baltimore ravens the
only thing those two teams have in
common right now is they have purple in
their color scheme the ravens come in at
number three on the pft 2020 preseason
power rankings we have worked our way
from 32 all the way up to the final
three and there they are
and yes the ravens who
for most of the season last year we
thought would end up number one top of
the stack world champion something
happened on the way to the super bowl
however and that was the tennessee
titans chris going into the season
though after 14 and two last year and
you know they started off two and two
yeah and there was a question what is
this team really going to be and then
they rattled off 12 straight wins to end
the season so
uh where do you see this ravens team
another year of experience for lamar
jackson but another year for defenses to
try to figure out how to stop him yeah
that's that's going to be the thing i
mean first off i expect the baltimore
ravens like you do to be a force in the
nfl i think there's no doubt about it
they're one of the three best teams in
football if you put them in number one i
don't think i would have been mad i
think it's the most talented roster in
the nfl
talent depth has it all size toughness
physicality has it all they got some
scary dudes on that team they are they
got it all speed everything so when you
look at it from that standpoint you go
okay that's special good coach we know
that john harbaugh is good as it gets
yeah lamar jackson that's going to be a
big thing we know that i mean first off
i don't think they're going to be able
to run him as much as he used to run
last year and things like that they got
to be a little careful and they got
other running backs to give the ball to
it's like you always talk about just the
threat of him alone
running the football will create a lot
of havoc for defenses to begin with but
the next phase or next level up as far
as being a drop back passer and thrower
and quarterback and all those type
things yeah lamar jackson that'll be a
big thing for me to watch this year we
saw a huge step you know between the
rookie year into last year but the other
reason i think we got to take this into
effect you know the ravens were
the the talk of the town last year they
were the team in the nfl
i know there's a lot of teams that have
put a little work on
whoa how do we deal with this running
quarterback lamar jackson baltimore
ravens type offense so there's gonna be
teams that are gonna be on
you know what they do more than they
were last year and i do think because of
that that is why it'll be important for
lamar jackson to
continue this growth in the passing game
because what we've seen in the two
playoff losses is two teams who have
kind of been like oop we got a beat on
your run game we can slow it down
now you guys are gonna have to throw to
beat us
and that hasn't worked out for baltimore
yet and he's been a little unlucky lamar
jackson and all that but still i think
that's the one area improvement of his
game to where he can go to almost
unstoppable level if he can get a little
bit better at that
yeah and look i think we're going to see
teams be physical with lamar jackson
first you have to catch him but i think
back to 2012 when rg3 was taking the
league by storm washington had a game in
pittsburgh
and they hit him every chance they could
get ryan clark explained after the fact
that was the plan that was the play
rainy day in pittsburgh i remember it
lamar jackson is a larger guy and maybe
can take it better than rg3 could have
but that's what they did they sent rg3
out on a pass route which was a huge
mistake because then they had open
season on griffin down the field that
game but you know i i think that teams
are gonna
again you have to get close enough to
him he's so elusive that it may not
matter but but they're going to want to
prove
like you're saying yeah they're going to
want to make them pay
and the teams that can are the teams
that will the problem is and you know
we've talked about this before as it
relates to scout team you can put
together the perfect scout team game
plan for how to stop lamar jackson but
when you get out into the real game
there's a huge difference between your
scout team quarterback and lamar jackson
and and he's just a blur and i think
that as long as he can move like that
play like that it's going to be hard to
stop him yeah i agreed i mean you can't
emulate him i don't care what what
position he plays his feet are as good
as anybody in football i mean they're
special feet i mean he could you know he
can be some sort of dancer and you know
again i think too
the thing that i like about what they've
done there you know there's a few things
that jump out you know first off we know
that offensive line is powerful
but like when we talk about the next
step in the passing game i would i would
be shocked if it doesn't happen this
year i mean hollywood brown last year he
came in you know with no training camp
because he was dealing with a foot
injury and then he had to deal with that
during the year
and we never really saw an emergence of
a
legitimate second receiver so i i would
expect that we find more of that we know
the tight end's good they got the devin
duvernay out of texas who's a great
weapon i think for this offense too at
wide receiver and could probably run the
ball a little bit and then the jk
dobbins factor so they got more to worry
about this year than they did last year
and i would expect guys like hollywood
and lamar and j.k dobbins to really jump
on the scene here to give teams more to
think about as far as stopping the
ravens schematically and personnel wise
and what they can do
yeah they've got significant
expectations for hollywood brown this
year myles boykin also drafted last year
he regarded his rookie season as a
disappointment you know the problem is
when you don't throw the ball like other
teams you're not going to generate
gigantic numbers and they had the
flirtation at least some of the players
did with antonio brown they brought in
dez bryant for a workout you know is
this a team when you consider the
receivers they have
could they be keeping an extra close eye
on the waiver wire to see who may come
available what veteran may get cut
whether there's a possibility to throw a
late round draft pick to get some guy
who may be on his last leg somewhere
else but who could come in and provide
leadership and and just a different
element uh to that baltimore receiving
corps yeah i mean i wouldn't be shocked
if that type of move was made i mean i
think there's a reason we heard heard
their name affiliated with antonio brown
and a few other free agent receivers
here in the off season because they
don't have that guy dez bryant was there
for a workout i think a lot of that will
depend on you know where where is chris
snead at uh or not willie sneed sorry
where's he at as a player because he
seems to be kind of on a downward arc of
their football team or on his career and
i just don't know who that second guy is
going to be for their offense so yeah
does a miles boykin who you mentioned
does he step up during training camp
this is what stinks about no preseason
because we usually have these context
clues to where we start going whoa
preseason game number two that guy was
in with the first team and oh they
designed a few plays for him he must be
impressing in camp
you know so i don't know but i guess if
you made me guess
i would put my money on duvernay i think
he's a really good football player
physical can break tackles can do things
after the catch and i think he would fit
within the realm of their offense almost
like a demo samuel type right where he
has jet sweeps and tosses and balls over
the middle where he just rips out of the
air and breaks tackles and things like
that but uh
it's going to be about evaluating their
guys here and just seeing what they got
and if they're comfortable with what
they got
and at the end of the day it's 11 guys
on defense you can only deploy the
resources in a certain way and if you
are trying your best to shut down the
running game that will have lamar
jackson that will have mark ingram and
rookie jk dobbins you're going to have
favorable match ups yeah secondary no
doubt as we saw week one of last year
when brian flores in his debut with the
dolphins sold out to stop the run and
repeatedly got burned over the top what
was the final score that game like 59 to
10. something crazy ridiculously obscene
like that yeah so that that's that's the
challenge and if they can get a game
breaker and if and that's why they have
so much faith in hollywood brown because
he's the guy who's going to run by
everybody and then all of a sudden oh
crap we have to double this guy then it
becomes easier to run the football one
thing they're being very coy about they
were like this last year they're doing
it this year and it's smart they're not
telling us how often they're going to
run lamar jackson sure and and i think
and maybe they're getting to the point
where it can be game plan specific you
know chris as he develops as a passer
him running the ball doesn't have to be
the centerpiece of every week's game
exactly maybe maybe some weeks you you
see what the defense is trying to take
away and you say fine pick your poison
we'll get you with our passing game and
and then every week can be like miami or
or they they start loading up to stop
the pass and then you can unleash the
run i mean that's ideally where you want
to be as an offense where you can do
both so well that you've got every
defense scared crapless
and they guess wrong about what they're
going to try to take away that week and
you just hit them with the other thing
yeah no i mean they can put you in a
bind this football team and we haven't
even talked about their tight ends they
got phenomenal tight ends too so they
can get in these sets where they can
overpower you physically in the run game
but yet have speed at receiver and
things that can run by you and be scary
that way and hey there was a number to
what you're saying mike i mean go back
and watch lamar jackson's highlights
last year there's a number of touchdown
passes he throws people are wide open
and that's because of the threat of him
running in their running game and
defenses are handcuffed because it's
such a
weapon and what they can do with lamar
jackson in the running game that it
handcuffs defense to have to play things
that they don't want to play like they
don't want to put two safeties you know
six feet from the line of scrimmage like
the dolphins did or think about the
buffalo bills game up there in buffalo
he threw a long post down the middle
there wide open touchdown because the
safeties were so worried about the run
game and getting gashed with that that
it's like oh wait i forgot this guy can
throw 60 yard lasers
so the threat to what you always say is
really the big thing the threat of him
running it's not about he's got to run
it 15 or 20 times a game it's just about
oh we think he might he could do that
and now because of that we're gonna have
to play certain defenses because we
don't have enough people to
fill all the gaps to stop these run
schemes that baltimore does
if you're a defensive coordinator which
offense creates more headaches for you
baltimore with that run-based attack
that can pivot to passing or the chiefs
where you have to deal with the play
that's called and the play that patrick
mahomes comes up with on the fly when
that play falls apart yeah i mean that's
it's brutal and brutal is what that is
trying to figure those i think as a
defensive coordinator i would think you
would have more issues schematically
with baltimore because of just so many
personnel sets different formations guys
go in different ways you know kansas
city it's of course andy reid's always
going to have a few wrinkles but it's
also just more about the players and his
aggressiveness in his play calling not
necessarily where teams are like oh gosh
i don't know what they're gonna do or
i've never seen this formation or
anything like that
it's more about the packaging i guess i
should say in kansas city so i would
think the baltimore gives more headaches
to defense to coordinators
wasn't it the titans that eventually
conceded in the postseason we're not
going to get patrick home so don't even
bother blitzing yeah i mean you know i i
wonder how much this year we're going to
see that chess match where maybe you
don't send maybe you drop eight guys
into coverage right i mean remember last
year going into the season the
the evolution of mahomes was to be
patient because they're going to take
away yeah everything what if they what
if they just decide they're going to
take away everything what if they dr
what if they do like the the patriots
did to the rams in super bowl 36 and
consistently drop eight guys into
coverage yeah and and just and just
concede because we know what and it's
supposed to be about the ravens but i'm
fascinated by this possibility yeah as
we as we speculate on what defenses are
going to do i just wonder whether or not
they're just going to accept the fact
we're not going to catch the guy and
he's better when he's running around
with his hair on fire he seems to throw
the ball more accurately with more
velocity when he's caught in a trap
let's just let him stand back there in
the pocket and and uh cover all of his
receivers and he doesn't have anything
yeah well i i
i hear you and there's teams that have
done that and have had success i mean
that's why the chargers had success two
years ago it's why the colts beat them
in the regular season last year it's why
the 49ers gave them a tough time for
three and a half quarters it's all that
same scheme it was a seattle scheme
let's rush four let's drop seven you're
saying let's drop one more guy into
coverage and you're right you know
that's gonna cause some issues the big
thing there would be like andy reid hey
you got clyde edwards hillary you gotta
be maybe a little more patient with the
run and then the other thing is this
mike i don't think you could live doing
that to mahomes because
like a brady or an aaron rodgers he's so
smart he's going to say said hut he's
going to pull away from the center he's
going to realize whoa they're only
rushing three coaches told me when they
rush three take my time don't make any
quick decisions they only got three i
got five maybe six guys blocking these
three plus we know how patient and good
he is in the pocket at drawing people in
and then stepping up or making a move
and to me that's where if you've dabbled
in that too much
he is going to compromise you at some
point to where okay now the three didn't
get there he's attacking the line of
scrimmage wait is he gonna run what's he
gonna do oh i think he's gonna run let
me run up and tackle him zoom oh no he
threw a laser right by my head to travis
kelsey for a 20 yard gain he'll
manipulate coverages and be more patient
i think he's just that kind of a
zen master to where it won't affect him
yeah i i agree with you there and again
both teams are going to give defense his
hand uh a handful every game all year
long let's get back to the ravens let's
talk about their defense yeah
they they cut old thomas uh and uh who
knows whether or not they missed a beat
because they haven't any preseason games
along with everyone else
is deshawn elliott ready to step in and
fill that role yeah team apparently
think so they wouldn't have cut our oil
thomas no i think that kind of says it
all exactly right and i you know i think
between desean elliot who's got some
talent certainly i mean he really does
got size got a little range you know i
watched him that texas you know i think
between him and then the fact that you
got a guy like we talked about last week
a little jimmy smith who could be that
make that charles woodson
rod woodson corner to safety type
transition where yeah maybe he can't run
the way he could but he's bigger
he's a pretty good tackler and maybe
they can put him in those positions too
if they don't feel totally comfortable
with desean elliot there right away but
yeah i mean baltimore's too smart we've
heard they were clamoring already some
of the players to bench earl thomas and
play desean elliott moore and i don't
think they would have gotten rid of earl
thomas unless you know they really felt
like hey we can survive without this guy
and our defense will be totally fine
which i expect it to be
now
what if i told you
that the ravens were in on yannick and
gawkway
hypothetically what if i told you i
wouldn't be shocked by that i wouldn't
be shocked i mean the ravens are always
looking
to
uh what do i want to say pillage the
biggest baddest dudes on the planet
every year i mean that's what they do
it's just the ravens are one of those
teams when you see them in person you go
holy crap now i understand why you guys
have been pushing around people for the
last 15 years and everybody's scared to
death of you guys they are size and
physicality and attitude and that's what
they so i wouldn't be shocked by that if
there's one little issue they have on
their defense mike it is a they don't
have a top-tier pass rusher i think
that's
that's
you know uh
that would be maybe my my one thing i
would say there
so uh let let's let's take it a step
farther then yeah because there's still
a pass rusher available
right and and i i know i don't know what
the hell is going to happen to davey and
clowney but could you imagine oh if
that's where he ends up oh
he would be like i mean he'd be he's
made to play for the ravens that's you
know i look at that and like the that's
why even the seattle way it fits his
style
but yeah just another big physical freak
out there you know
and and the ravens are just they're
growing on trees you know i don't know
if they can afford him i know the ravens
aren't in the best salary cap spot you
know but
yeah either way they're going to be fine
because uh because wink martindale is
unbelievable at dialing up blitzes being
creative and then the big thing is mike
they probably got arguably the best duo
corner corner corners in football right
it's them the patriots maybe the
dolphins are in that conversation now
with their guys you have that with the
creative scheme size up front kaleas
campbell to get in the mix now
patrick queen
a middle linebacker who's going to be
flying all over the field first round
out of lsu like they improved their team
their team is awesome and i would argue
they were one of the teams that won the
offseason this year too
um the uh
the reality you mentioned the titans
like how do how does that
factor into their approach to this
season when they have as their most
recent memory
from playing a game that they got their
butts kicked defensively yeah all the
great stuff they did all year long it
gets thrown away in one fell swoop yeah
it's it's crushing i'm sure it's still
on their mind and bothers them i mean
yeah they were set up to win the super
bowl
you know i i have a hard time thinking
the ravens are going to sit here and
emulate 14 and 2 again mike i don't know
about you like i could see more of like
almost a chief's way to the super bowl
this year like where hey
okay yeah this second year you know
we're we're in the playoffs we're one of
the top few seeds but we're not the
number one seed this year and now we
make a run to the super bowl i wouldn't
be shocked if that's the way it goes
this year i don't expect baltimore to be
14 and two i think that division is
going to be better that's gonna give
them a few more losses i still think
they're in the playoffs but i don't
think it's guaranteed that like they're
the number one seed this year
and look you know how it's gonna go and
as they get closer and closer to the
playoffs as they get ready for that
first playoff game whether it's wild
card rounder division around we're going
to hear it over and over again uh can
they finally win a playoff game with
lamar jackson the quarterback and as
they continue to lose in the first
playoff game they have that's going to
get louder and louder like it did for
the bengals when they were one and done
five straight seasons all right best
case worst case for the ravens this year
i mean they can win the super bowl i i
don't have any doubt about that i mean
you know you sit here right now i think
i'm with you i expect it to be kansas
city and baltimore in the afc
championship game more than likely than
not um and the worst case
worst case is like a seven seat i don't
think it could get much worse than that
worst case is it's like 10 and six
in the tough division the steelers and
the browns all were good this year but
they still got in and are still one of
the better teams in football and have a
chance to go on a super bowl run
yeah i agree with you best case win the
super bowl worst case another one and
done which really is worst case i think
it's
is it better to not make the playoffs
than to have another one and done i hear
you because it's definitely gonna add to
that conversation you're right i mean
really ultimately yeah it probably would
be if you knew you're gonna go one and
done you'd rather rather not go because
you're right now you're gonna go into
that fourth year and that's all
anybody's gonna talk about you know john
harbaugh lamar jackson can't win a
playoff game together they can't win a
playoff game lamar jackson can't win a
playoff game what's the matter with him
why can't he do it i mean that's all
they'll hear if that happens again this
year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports